this this has been going on for a long
long time way before President Obama but
it seems to have exploded under
President Obama if you want to be an
ambassador to a foreign country you
pretty much just have to bundle campaign
money and you will become an ambassador
we have 24 bundlers right now these are
the people that find the guys that are
donating a lot of money they bundle the
money together and then they give it to
to the PACs that are better working for
the politicians and 24 of these guys are
headed to Western Europe right now to be
our new ambassadors and here's a video
it's about a minute and a half long
which I know is very long for you too
but I think you can do it of John McCain
interviewing a potential ambassador to
Norway
mr. Souness following last year's
parliamentary elections Norway's
Conservative Party now had a
centre-right coalition as you know that
will include the anti-immigration party
called the Progress Party what do you
think the appeal of the Progress Party
was to the Norwegian voters Thank You
senator it's a very seminal question
generally Norway has and is very proud
of being a very open transparent and
democratic parliamentary government one
of the byproducts of being such an open
society and placing such a value on free
speech is that you get some fringe
elements that have a microphone that
spew their hatred and although I will
tell you Norway has been very quick to
denounce them we're going to continue to
work with Norway to make sure government
has denounced them that got the
coalition gummed a part of the coalition
of the government well I would say you
know what
I scream correct I stand corrected the I
stand corrected would like to leave my
answer at they are it's a very very open
society
and that most Norwegians the
overwhelming amount of Norwegians and
the overwhelming uh amount of people in
Parliament uh don't feel the same way I
have no more questions for this
incredibly highly qualified group of
nominees okay so that's Jane soon as he
was trying to become the ambassador to
Norway he has literally no idea what
he's talking about James openness
sorry George James soon as all three of
their names mr. George liked it again
it's just it's three dumb names it just
just George do you think he was trying
to do that to pass because he's like I
don't know what I'm saying but I throw
in the third name it sounds a little
more I tell you this uh I think that's a
guy constantly reminded me of gene
Simmons like a guy constantly desperate
to tell you how smart is right he's so
insecure about how dami secretly is yeah
feels a need to impress gene Simmons
always using big words slightly
incorrectly and then kind of be like
you're just said uh that and he and
right at the beginning of that answer
and we'd seen it in the pre you know we
had a shorten that clip you did Dave but
there's like two minutes before that
where he's just the middlee given an
answer he just runs out of steam it's
important in Norway to continue to
gather information and grow many
industries such as they I'm not even
exam and they days a glass of water he's
like okay and then put gas another
questions like thanks for bailing me out
you were just talking though so like and
then at the beginning of that answer to
McCain he says was very seminal question
so I guess the word of the day today was
seminal well what would a seminal I was
trying I wanted to ask you guys seminal
question I really couldn't come up with
something that was seminal it's a
seminal look is it embarrassing and this
is published of the public record no you
know this is like this is not a closed
session yeah this is a not just this guy
it's a it's a board right of all the
different people who are trying to get
this ambassadorship none of which are
well qualified yes
literally you don't have to have ever
visited the country you want to be
ambassador to be for Argentina or a
potential ambassador right you don't
have to you don't have to technique many
play many places but he hasn't had the
chance yet to visit my country he wants
to write you imagine the first time you
show up at a country you're like I'm the
ambassador never been here before don't
even know where Starbucks is and I'm
gonna I'm gonna walk off the plane and
insult a major branch of the gut not a
branch but a major party within the
government yeah I was in this the worst
kind of you know reset you know Obama
wanted to reset our foreign relations
obviously we find relations with nori
but is the worst kind of things I think
people think about America we're gonna
send some schmuck who literally doesn't
know what parties are in the government
to be our impact yes but if you honestly
I but I'm not giving Obama pass at all
but I will say at least if you look at
this late article that kind of uh shows
all the different would be a matter um
all of the ones to countries where we
have no relations issues are the ones
that were bundlers the all of the
ambassadorships to places where there's
actual potential conflict those are
people who have worked you know in
foreign relations before that that's a
pretty tepee it is it it so they're it's
a it's it's broken out into thirds right
it's it's it's bundlers people who have
no business working as these ambassadors
that another third is people who were
previous ambassadors or people who work
for the state Department and another
third I don't remember what there was a
third color it was their beds got the
computer what that third color career
diplomat diplomat other political
appointees and then these bumblers for
Obama and if you look at where the
butler's for Obama are heavily uh uh are
densely populated it's all in Europe
with Western Europe or in any others
like Dominican Republic like now they're
nice kids yeah but they're always they
are it didn't it in not so much Obama's
defense in the defense of because it
abama
they say he's doing it in to a greater
extent than Clinton Bush or bush or Bush
uh but they uh but the other I'm not
quite buying that like I don't so it I
mean I'm not I'm they're not wrong
I just mean this is always you know
Shirley Temple died yesterday Shirley
Temple this great delightful star and
then in 1950 she gets married for this
second time to this she's 22 never went
to college
I should pretty well-educated on a lot
but nonetheless so she goes she marries
the second get married 18 marry again 22
to this big Republican and she becomes a
Republican fundraiser Shirley Temple and
she doesn't make it as an adult star and
then Richard Nixon names our special
ambassador to the UN yeah then she
becomes ambassador to Ghana and then in
1989 she was ambassador Czechoslovakia
at the end as sort strikes me that maybe
that was a tiny bit important at that
point yeah Sonia and that said and yet
that said everybody said she did great
so you know that you could rise to the
challenge but it it's all right it's not
it's not saying that automatically these
people are going to find out but it is
interesting that I guess grenadine sales
were probably funding the Republican
Party in the deficit that but what's up
the UH it's a delicious member it just
what everybody liked but I think what we
learn from this is that the ambassador's
in places where we have as you said good
non-controversial relations don't do
anything that's not really important
that that post in England or that post
in France or all these places Norway
presumably that job is getting run by
the deputy ambassador who's the career
ambassador who does the actual protocol
stuff in this guy host dinners and meets
people and shakes hands and I present PR
that's good that said that's clearly
what's happening
that's dumb red and if you're trying to
reset government say huge mistake so
okay so then we'll we'll end on this and
so going back to the money in politics
thing that we ended the previous segment
so that's why to me this seems worse
with Obama because he wanted to
fundamentally change the way we do
business or at least that's what he said
he was gonna do and like this to me is
the most obvious blatant example of just
by a post just by exact so shouldn't we
hold into a little bit of a higher
standard there very interesting very
cush job yeah that's that's exactly
what's happening you know and it's it's
insane to me that what are they're not
qualified is there nobody in this
country who knows a lot about the
Norwegian government is there nobody in
this country who's actually qualified to
have that post
are there no career diplomats who could
be doing this regiment
you know more about Norway there are
people this to the rivers bit there's
people in that Norway staff who
presumably could just go on exactly
growing up in DC a number of our friends
were career diplomats and they like
they're all they were always the
smartest people in the wincing hear me
is that why would Obama do something
like this again knowing that we are
going to find out about it you know his
constituents are going to be watching
this happening and saying god dammit
you're letting us down again you
campaigned on these on these very
specific goals and we all rally behind
you and now you're proving yourself to
be such a hypocrite yeah well our money
in politics I don't think he cares and
it's all about money in politics Costas
is got a home it's the HBO vice
president yeah not even the President
and what's he known as a reporter not
nominated to Spain and Andorra yeah and
their door yeah that's just because it's
not TV it's a big pretty cushy gig